dead a big guitar Hotel on the Las Vegas
Strip today Hard Rock International
presented its early renderings of its
newly acquired strip property Sasha
Loftus joins us live from outside the
Mirage the future location of the new
Hard Rock property in town Sasha
and we finally have a
half earlier this year Hard Rock entered
into an agreement to purchase the Mirage
and really completely change it up now
earlier today the Nevada Gaming Control
Board recommended approval of the
purchase now they need the gaming
commission to approve it that hearing is
December 22nd Hard Rock Internationals
submitted its application including
renderings with a design for the guitar
tape shape tower that everyone's been
talking about those behind the plans say
their goal is to create a style similar
to the other Hard Rock locations around
the country and we spoke with some on
the Strip today to see how they feel
about this plan
I do travel around a lot and there's
just I think there's enough Hard Rock
Cafes as is
um and it becomes too uniform there are
the trade-offs because you can hold on
to the past or you can agree to move on
to the Future and I think that would be
the
now the hotel will have over 3 600 rooms
and 174
000 square feet of Casino space
Renovations also planned for Villas a
private gaming room event and meeting
spaces now the Mirage will continue to
operate as normal until plans for the
Hard Rock are finalized and the Hard
Rock itself is set to open sometime in
2025. reporting live on the Las Vegas
Strip tonight social Loftus 8 News Now